it's trailer commentaries you might have
to clip the 66 the 66th Batman film with
Joe Danielle Dan and if you haven't seen
this show we talked about the thought
process our true uncensored thoughts
about the honest trailer and then we
watch it and come in we have some
deleted scenes at the end we respond to
your comments so helpfully and then we
tease what next week is gonna be so yeah
flashing back to 1966 mm-hmm Batman the
TV show has been on the air for one year
you know and this drops in the theaters
I wish I was there man seems groovy up
shows amazing I got fat anyone who
doesn't like Batman 66 I have this
memory of an episode and I couldn't find
it on YouTube of like Batman and I
believe Robin they're just in a field
and the Joker like rides up on them in
like a cherry picker some kind of piece
of construction equipment and he's got
frozen swordfish like he and his goons
have to have fish and they send their
throat they're just hand throwing fish
that's the first one I saw also the
Joker and it was the Joker and Batman it
culminates in a surf off between Yoker
communicates with his goons through
talking through a hot dog walking to so
it's like what's the point
oh yeah cuz my mom like loved it and she
called me into the room cuz it was the
bat to see one and that was
because every time I came on my mom
would watch it and then they used to
play like on base that and then Wonder
Woman would come right after yeah I just
wanted King Tut to be in Batman 89 like
I remember being a little kid like all
my favorite villains big man this was
Batman to me like I didn't when I was a
kid I didn't get that it was funny or
silly
it was just like Batman's awesome his
car is awesome and he's punching those
guys yeah I mean it's greatest Batman's
such a flexible character like he can be
the Dark Knight but he can also be a
super friend no he can't really be one
okay yeah unarmed dangerous oh but also
know Paris yeah I'll take this Batman
over the current iteration but we all
get the Batman we deserve and our times
deserve a murder a murder man you know
with a gun car this Batman all the
Batman's murder that I don't know where
that came from his one rule is probably
the one rule he breaks the most often
yeah yeah I mean he did he didn't want
to he did the bomb you know movie Batman
is more flexible more rural flexible
than a Comics Batman yeah yeah yeah well
any other thoughts before we dive right
in I know Pattinson is going this route
I hope Matt Reeves shocks us all and
they go full well Chum into the bad
verse yeah yeah yeah there should be a
cross by I'm sure there has been let's
watch our honest trailer for Batman the
TV show the movie 1967 I'm in there
[Music]
before you've experienced Joaquin
Phoenix's twisted take on the Joker
revisit the shocking origins of
live-action Batman as a swinging cartoon
crime buster
[Music]
some days you just can't get rid of a
bomb because just cuz like I know we all
talk about how ironically funny some of
this stuff is that seen as genuinely
hilarious this hike that is like high
comedy this idea of just like he's got
the bomb and it's when they all come
together and he's going down and he runs
into the same band again then the same
nuns again and they're the same it's
just like this movie is a genuinely
funny comedy and was meant to be like
not ironically funny but actually funny
yeah but well I think that this is it's
like today's Pixar movies or like
spongebob or something where this is
made for children but they were winking
at the adults in the audience like you
also get something to purchase Meredith
has like my favorite line reading and
the whole thing when they've already
dehydrated the the goons the guinea pigs
and of course Catwoman is sweeping it up
and he's like careful each one of them
has a mother it's like the most subtle
thing of a home purchase Meredith if you
watch they're all having a good time
burgess Meredith in particular there's
one thing that it's like a great cut is
they're sitting there I think it must
have been improvised they're sitting
there in a penguin I think it's what
they're talking about the carrier
pigeons are sitting there and they're
talking and like a cat one was just like
Oh everything's going perfectly the plan
and then she like reaches across and
like touches penguins hand and verges
where there's six girls cut away super
quick there's a lost art here I think
it's later in the trailer but when
they're like a sparrow and a sparrow
with a machine gun
yeah and Gordon just goes of course
there's just a lost art of deadpan
absurd comedy yeah it's a little like
it's kind of a like Kung Pao into the
fists or something where it's kind of
just a parody of it's the serialized
detective stories going on at the same
time yeah I mean it's full Leslie
Nielsen the airplane yeah good times
alright let's keep going
Batman the old TV show the movie you
love the dark Batman defining
performances of Keaton Bale and a flag
take you back to Batman's roots a
bachelor who lives with a teenage boy is
hot there was something funny when we
were looking at the teenage boy steps
because he also lives with his aunt
Harriet Harriet they added the rumors of
any kind of impropriety of the time to
go away but oh if this aunt as well then
there's no hanky-panky cook nothing
crazy would be going on with them
cosplaying in a cave if their aunt is
upstairs things about Bruce and - oh but
aunt Harriet's there oh well during the
etiquette no room for sitting with all
those cats good times it's funny because
in the tea that she's she doesn't even
have a line in the movie she's just like
waged but in the TV show she's also like
the most naive yet easily duped like
she's not like it's not like she's there
like I am on to you and they have to be
like she's also just like the queen is
Harriet but when this was created whoa
was it normal to have a ward I was a kid
I thought it was normal was for sure the
way that there used to be princes and
princesses with my kid thoughts there
used to be Ward right in the Gilded Age
did people did like the Rockefellers
have wards the Greeks did
the Industrial Revolution everyone had
an apprentice I don't know it's so
whatever yeah I think Ward is like I
want to adopt you as my son but let's
keep this casual but we're just talking
I'm gonna see other words no one said
the D word
sent all down there chub we haven't
signed the papers yet there's other boys
in my life okay let's keep going with
the trailer we did it isn't exactly in
peak human condition girl but to the
changing to the changing societal views
on what is someone rightfully pointed
out it is true Adam West was not in bad
shape
yeah yeah he was just in normal shape
for that time which that's not like yeah
but Batman isn't a normal shape
laverne's hotel matter what time he's in
Batman is not in normal shape doubt in
his earlier days he was he seemed like
an old-timey like barrel yeah but
everyone was because all they ate was
liver and stuff guys it's like in the
old days of pro wrestling when all those
guys just looked like just a guy that
hasn't left a bar in seven days I don't
believe that any of them are actually
strong the same way that our friend if
he says he's gonna could beat a gorilla
I think that any of us can you have
could beat anybody from the forties
way out of Westwood rip me at half are
you kidding me they were all smoking all
the time and eating organ meats they
made them impervious to pain the only
workouts they did was like standing into
like a machine that like did like this
they were lifted those like cannonballs
darnell males and barbells maybe you
think you can step to me because
sometimes you take two ropes and go well
no I had 14 sticks this week fine I
challenge any old-timey strongman fight
right here right now in this year I
drink six eggs I'm always impressed by
you all right keep going greatest
generation keep your hands off his girl
show me mr. kicker or I'll wreck this
place with my dying breath inform that
girl kill you all random interpretation
they can only be described as the love
child of Christopher Walken and Jeff
Goldblum the criminal catalyst in this
entire affair our old arch it's totally
like the veil Jeff called was just doing
Adam West's Batman like is Adam West's
Batman without any costume you've been
exposed Goldblum we know your deal just
a more arms yeah yeah keep trying to
remember this is aligned our arch enemy
the say okay find your apartment save
your yeah yeah there you have it
I didn't expect it I didn't expect to
demystify Jeff Goldblum I did feel good
about it I just adds to the mystique for
me play you already knew that
Robin sucked okay we knew that this
would cause controversy and it sure did
I got a lot of guff for Oh what about
Nightwing what about not in a movie no
no nor in a TV show okay not animated
animated yeah but the main most of the
major portrayals of Robin have been at
best
innocuous yep and worst he's a
counterintuitive character yeah I think
it says something to me that the people
that are coming to Robin's defense a lot
of them are saying like well obviously
you've forgotten about Nightwing and Red
Hood
no because you guess what their names
ain't Robin that's not relevant
that's not Robin if your defense of
Robin is to refer to later iterations of
the character who used to be Robin who's
cool I think that serves our point yeah
a little bit it's again we're talking
about specifically in the movies we've
all read comic books we know that some
of we know Damian is pool and murdery or
whatever but that's not what we're
talking about yeah you know what
ultimately they're all pretty dumb shoes
has a big yellow cape I don't care if
he's at one point was a weird murder
prodigy very try hard it's like
Nightwing's but no quite impressive be a
whole snack he's dummy thick
oh he dummy thing it goes right up there
with Tom Hollands Rhianna umbrella
rendition as far as just like modern
interpretations of superhero sexuality
in the current line yes but how can he
sneaked up on goons when his cheeks clap
[Laughter]
did you know always sobbed watch
Batman's original sidepiece perfect
sidekick shield for the dogs support
your police no he belongs to - suggest
eugenics I'll activate the computer link
feed in the various ethnic why didn't we
call them proudly member you're mine
Fritz starring I mean first of all I
think YouTube would have showed up at
our door with their slip telling us we
might yes this is the content we crave
that you like to know the SJW messages
in there's a bell curve there for the
[Applause]
yes yeah we didn't we didn't put it in
here but there is actually a scene where
after the hilarious bomb gag where Robin
is like you risked your life for them
people in a bar like Robin has
determined that he himself is the
arbiter for who lives and who dies
Gotham City yeah yeah what a square
square rights and cool
swing it yeah yeah they may be drinkers
Robin but there's still people this has
to be explained
yes exactly yes I forgotten this is the
first time that had clicked with me that
Robin in the attempt to save the leaders
of the world suggests his own form of a
master are routed by himself and Batman
alone God the natural order of things
it's a race master dick they aren't even
all puns it's like a verbal tic somebody
help this boy in Gotham is a group of
criminals so crooked even the cameras
are at an angle Dutch angles judge
Raymond a devious diva whose ratio of
catch a woman is about nine to ten the
penguin who can only speak in nautical
jargon because most of this movie takes
place at sea for some reason I'm just
curious a lot more than what the
decision-making process was obviously
they aren't shooting in New York City
they just have like a pool either the
one at the Warner a lot or at the Fox
backlot someone was like it's open for
the week yeah they're like rewrites
I think Kirk Douglas had finished
shooting the submarine picture yeah we
just wrapped on victory at sea I think
that take might be the same take from
the true which you oh yeah it's been in
many other there's like there's like
legit there's like two big water tanks
and Hollywood and it's all every movie
is in yeah yeah it's back when again the
time period where I could beat any of
them up where every every movie was like
about like waterskiing on each other's
shoulders enough of those movies that
they needed to build their own studio
what Beach is Elvis gonna be on next
yeah it'sit's one of those pictures and
yeah it's just the most sun-drenched
Gotham that takes place apparently at
the beach or the harbor or the Century
City even when they aren't on the beach
they make sure they show us bikini babes
yes I appreciate they found a way with
Jack LaLanne was a shackle instructor on
the roof a young Jack LaLanne known
today for pulling um the cruise ships
with his teeth which again I maintain is
it really that hard
they're already floating you know isn't
it like that they're weightless
basically anyone could pull it with
their Jack LaLanne could Klaus way out
of script right now tear us all in half
smoke a cigarette
drink a shake and get back in the crave
I love how many people are getting mad
at me right now on behalf of the
[Laughter]
pre-world War two after World War two
now pre ww2 I'm talking like like like
Rockefeller like curled mustache unitard
of course you can beat the hell out of
the Great Gatsby eating oysters
rockefeller and clams casino you have
the kind of Constitution you have to
have to drink nothing but whiskey
nothing but we call it seafood at all
Kentucky rocks no course we can't eat it
Chipotle burrito we had to go home early
from work these guys were doing 19-hour
days keeping up mistresses and working
for 14 hours or visiting coal mines on
nothing but Ryan
Lobster Thermidor down on ether to cure
their Dipsy or whatever
from this side of the state to the other
they did not greetings Travis is more
dangerous equivalent Dipsy I don't know
I don't know my diseases I'll probably
get in trouble we're soft you got city
boy hands mr. oppa what did he do well
Quint went down a shark's gullet and
ones bites okay so how'd your granddad's
boy going grandpa the Riddler
the perfect sixties villain because
you'd have to be on acid to follow his
peril with the machine gun and the Joker
the first DC star to try and fail to
cover up a moustache together donor to
pull off the oldest caper in the book
turn world leaders into dust with a
dehydrating God meant for whiskey
production Ben ransom each country for a
billion dollars will be delivered via
carrier pigeon while they make their
getaway in a surplus military not the
people they become is like a rosy bin
even the test subjects I believe we're
all in color or were they all the same
yeah they were all the same color we're
all like grave-robbing color and then of
these I guess it's based on their
outfits right the more color fur you are
you get well
it's many of our governor's brought up a
wonderful can we go back to the shop
where they snap back into reality again
if you'll notice the equipment still in
place
so yeah the snap the implications of the
snap that happened to somebody in the
Marvel Universe I'm sure yeah I'm sure
yeah okay
anyways let's finish this bad boy ah too
late
maybe so revisit a simpler time about
Motors admin building a fort bat fans
were happy to watch a good old fashioned
punch mob
[Applause]
no one stressed the consequences of the
world's diplomats having their brains
and bodies grab the door behind us
Batman super seriously
[Music]
no my age it's beating the angst do ya
pause I mean this is why and I can see
the like red sniper dot from Disney
appearing on my head right now like
these superheroes should all just be
public domain by now and like any like
Robin Hood or whatever like anyone can
make a Batman movie at this point
because there's so many different takes
on them and like you can do spider-man
seven different ways and same way with
that man everyone can get the Batman or
the Superman or whatever that they want
that they need so they're also like they
were all invented 70-plus years ago and
they were all stolen from the people who
created them anyways so like let's just
let everyone take a crack know gave me
Batman mm sure yeah I want a Batman in
the early 2000s yeah gin code or in the
future give me Batman 2046 yeah I want
it it's actually pretty clean up this
drone is slightly smaller eleventeen is
it it Biden won't like this old job
[Laughter]
alright is that it now let's keep going
story the masked swinger Captain
Underpants girl field Meredith hey Sarge
sometimes you have to explains people
just like yeah way to do an old that way
to do said out-of-date Irish voice
garden oh boy wonder being great when
they see what you're up to
bagora Botwin yes that's the one Eric
ters is supposed to be he is he's who
does nothing but stand in the
commissioner's office with the
commissioner and wait for the same
things that the Commissioner is waiting
for and then London sees his only job
appears to be to run up to the roof and
turn on the bat-signal again sweetie
that's back in that area you could get a
job doing that and have a family of six
how's the air yeah super blinding bat
speed
that cameras polarized bat filter bat
scanner tracking the stolen Batmobile
perfectly quickly be a bat-cycle to the
bat copter 24 bad bad so in $100 bills
1 billion us would wait 20,000 pounds
given an average carrier pigeon can lift
2.5 ounces and we take 128,000 trained
birds for the US alone that is a lot of
know I saw well actually that may have
actually been a useful well actually
which said that in 1960-61 hundred and
one thousand dollar bills were still in
circulation so it could have been only
twelve thousand that's what our point
yeah yeah
you've been got yeah well just save it
for just my brains been in power levels
mode right he's in one of which begins
when is this day next week some Thursday
one of the Thursday's yeah transition to
it happens yeah so get ready for that
and yeah but that's a very helpful well
actually so but that one was on me so
the the power levels you can yell at
actual physicists who I'm sure know
better than you I don't know about 12800
carrier pigeons it's not ridiculously
we're just Meredith could do that in a
week at yeah no problem
I mean that's like a third of Central
Park is covered in that amount of
pigeons and they're all trainable
trained everyone yeah let's play those
deleted scenes story oh job about a Boy
Wonder
holy your than now break me off a piece
of that get the cats bar kitty pryde
Cyrano de Bergerac Impractical Jokers
Gorge Massey let's go
and oh great Robyn's crotch wonderful
cannot see that now the door night you
know your high horse Batman you can't
even recognize your girlfriend was
Catwoman you know this girl did did we
just witness a premature evacuation
[Music]
[Laughter]
that's funny the words blue alright
let's talk about your comments corporate
rock writes how can you ignore the best
intro to the show ever made and the best
lyrics ever did this have the the Batman
intro forget no no okay well that's why
we ignore it yeah it starts with like
this whole like a brick wall thing and
it's like we want to thank the cops
which is a fantastic though again that's
how the Matt reaps Batman needs to start
a great doctor toes writes how do you
know so much about carrier pigeons I
used Wolfram Alpha to uh it has like the
the size and and data on everything so
you just type in like that was eight
billion dollars in carrier pigeon and
they'll solve that for you right I mean
really I mean there's a few intermediate
steps but like it just knows the size
and weight and it's like a smart smarter
Google that you can use okay check it
out play with it and none of your
business rights but you got to hand it
to them no Batmobile ever since has been
this cool look at the style of that
thing a freaking work beauty that is yes
oh yeah windows yeah I had the toy
because
the red we are at Toys R Us when I was a
kid and it was just out and not in a
package and I was like I want that and
they couldn't figure out they were like
I guess someone left it here and so I
just had that Batmobile between that in
the bat-cycle with like the bat sidecar
yeah oh the poor did you see how small
it was it was not a very large person
and he was like even he was like this a
little bigger yeah you get some new
Robin when they outgrow the cycles
outgrown you that's why it's just a ward
because that's not like a legally
binding thing yeah no commitments going
through wards all right well there you
go that's Batman 66 the honest trailer
and the honest trailer commentary unless
anyone has some super burning final
thoughts we will tease next week's
episode which will be Wow god I don't
know can someone else do this I can't
think of these on the spot it's like
it's far from home spider-man
[Laughter]
[Music]
you